[Musica]
questo è un caleidoscopio
immaginate di tenerne uno in mano
lasciate che i pezzi prendono forma
senza però perdere di vista l'unicità
dei pezzi del giallo rosso viola e tutti
gli altri colori
lasciatevi ispirare dal vedere bello ed
alle simmetrie che questo strumento
fatto di lenti ed i frammenti di vetro
permette questo invece è il mio
caleidoscopio ho collezionato i primi
pezzi la bambina ed è fatto di ricordi
perché i ricordi sono tutto i ricordi
hanno a che fare con la nostra identità
il mio caleidoscopio di bambina è
cresciuto insieme a me e con questo
nuovi pezzi nuove forme nuovi equilibri
e poi ho raccolto il tutto in un unico
mosaico sociale nel mio mosaico e
sociale dal mio arrivo qui in italia
alla sensazione di sentirmi altro in
classe alla voglia di arricchirmi di
diversità
mi sono diplomata ragioneria qui a
cesena e da lì subito sono entrata nel
mondo del lavoro e da subito ho voluto
entrare a far parte in quel melting pot
italiano in quel mosaico sociale che
permette la commissione gli elementi di
origine eterogenea di differenti
elementi che poi insieme costruiscono un
unico substrato fatto di tante
differenze differenze a livello
religioso culturale sociale ma che poi
alla fine rispetto a tutte le identità
il 28 novembre 2015 e il 19 marzo 2018
per me sono andate molto importanti che
hanno segnato in maniera indelebile la
mia vita e il mio senso di inclusività
era un sabato sera
staccavo dall ultimo giorno di fiera e i
miei amici erano fuori ad aspettarli in
macchina per andare al cinema
salì in quella macchina senza velo per
poi uscirne con il velo che indosso
tuttora tutti i giorni per mia libera
scelta ed è fantastico perché in quella
sera i miei amici mi hanno trasmesso
qualcosa di unico
cosa significa in realtà l'amicizia cosa
significa assecondare sì nonostante noi
tutti siamo diversi ed è semplicemente
un qualcosa di fin troppo inclusivo e
così mano a mano che misi il velo
iniziava già riscontrare l'esigenza di
trovare un posto che mi potesse dare
scelta perché se io quella sera mi sono
messa al velo
però non ho voluto rinunciare alla mia
eleganza e al mio stile e mi serviva un
posto dove potessi trovare l'equilibrio
tra l'essere musulmana e italiana
e così fu il 19 marzo 2018
io e la mia migliore amica fatichiamo
gradi
apriamo e giriamo le chiavi già paradise
qui il nostro luogo pieno di equilibrio
il nostro luogo pieno di scelta
il nostro luogo pieno di grinta perché
questo avevamo paura in primis i av
paura non sono cittadina italiana non
poteva accedere a bandi non potevo
accende accedere a fondi però potevamo
contare solo sui nostri risparmi e
questo crea paura perché incertezza
perché non è sicurezza però la paura in
gabbia
la paura è una trappola si chiude e ti
alza i muri non ti permette di
esprimerti
già paradise oltre ad essere scelta è
anche uno scrigno ma uno scrigno non
chiuso uno scrigno aperto pieno di
colori di tessuti l'equilibrio tra la
fede e la cittadinanza
noi siamo i primi a essere i primi non è
facile è una grande responsabilità
perché ne hai tanta verso la tua
comunità che è islamica ma anche verso
quella cittadinanza
la società italiana perché oltre a
creare un negozio crei un luogo mi sono
resa anche conto che l'essere umano non
è esente dal pregiudizio
la sera che dovevo incontrare il
proprietario dei muri sono caduta in
quella trappola e di cui avevo paura nel
pregiudizio del pregiudizio perché avevo
paura che potesse limitarmi oppure non
darmi il locale semplicemente perché
indosso il velo quando alla fine non è
andata per niente così oppure il giorno
dell'inaugurazione la ragazza del bar
poco più in là ci ha portato i fiori
come buon auspicio
e questo per noi era un qualcosa di
emozionante si tuttora ci sono persone
che si fermano la vetrina non se la
sentono di entrare sono curiosi
intimoriti però cos'è questo nel
rispetto di tutto quello che ci è
capitato di positivo cosa questo nel
sorriso nell'aiuto del custode di ogni
giorno negli anziani che ti camminano
davanti a rapporti td fanno i
complimenti non è nulla
tantissimi giornali hanno scritto su di
noi
e tantissimi per fortuna hanno trasmesso
veramente il nostro obiettivo
il nostro luogo di inclusività ed è
semplicemente fantastico perché è quello
a cui noi aspiriamo perché è quello per
cui noi cerchiamo ogni giorno di andare
avanti senza poi dopo porci dei muri
perché è quello che serve soprattutto
oggi giorno perché la necessità e la
madre dell'inventiva e noi ne abbiamo
creato un posto perché inclusi ta non
significa barricarsi e non dare la
possibilità agli altri di entrare in
contatto con noi inclusività non
significa tenere da parte il diverso e
inclusività non significa non poter fare
la propria parte nel proprio paese solo
perché ci sono dei limiti
io non posso votare però sogna un giorno
di poterlo fare perché è quello l'italia
è il mio paese è anche il mio paese
io mi sono vestita della mia conoscenza
e ora chiedo a voi di farlo non
integrando ma includendo grazie
[Applauso]